and it is time to celebrate
international waffle day and help a
great cause at the same time and here to
tell us more is the owner and creator of
tiabi coffee and waffle tiffany visco
and alan mcfaul from las vegas fire and
rescue paramedic and burn foundation
board member welcome you two thank you
for being here yeah i mean you had me at
waffles basically it's called waffles
for a cause tell us a little bit about
what you got going on well we're
celebrating international waffle day and
we wanted to involve the community and
kind of bring people together so we
decided to team up with this great
organization and this is our second time
having this waffle eating competition
and for every waffle
they eat we donate ten dollars to the to
your organization so the key is getting
these great men and women from
from your organization to eat as many
waffles as possible have you been
training for this alan i personally have
not been training we had a little
training session this morning where i
did two in two minutes
but some of some of our guys are really
going crazy with it they're doing
research online on how to do competitive
eating uh one of our guys zach lamboo
he's really getting after he's gonna
he's gonna surprise everybody how many
how many waffles do you think you'll be
able to eat in the five minutes me i
think i think four is going to be the
max
i'll go for more but we'll see what do
you think your best person is going to
get oh zach's going for 10.
because the record's what seven and a
half yeah so he's gonna be he's gonna
beat that for sure so every time they
eat one waffle again how much is that
ten dollars um towards the organization
so to the burn foundation tell us a
little bit about that so the burn
foundation is local here in las vegas
and the important thing about us is all
the dollars that we raise throughout the
whole year stay in the valley
our biggest thing is is really our toy
drive at the end of the year and it goes
to anybody that has a catastrophic event
so we'll look for any calls that we run
on where there might be a specific
family that we can help out
but the money that we raised throughout
the whole year goes to
everything throughout the whole year we
send kids to burn camp uh we donate to
different families that lose stuff in a
house fire specifically christmas time
you know it'd be horrible for somebody
not to have something to open on
christmas so we really strive for that
to be our big one that is so great that
you're doing this tiffany tell us why
you decided to have an event like this
for the community
um well we really like to involve
ourselves in the community and i just
you know international waffle day should
be it's more about our community coming
together and celebrating something that
we love doing making waffles and coffee
for
um the lost las vegas community so we
just thought let's just make it a
tradition and let's just have fun with
it okay well who wants to have a who
wants to have a race you want to go you
want to try it you want to get some okay
you doing with syrup or without no
without syrup oh okay can't do it okay
without syrup you can't do it no okay
how about how about one little one
little triangle of a triangle okay a
triangle without syrup who can do it
who's who's betting me and who's betting
who's running out or two yeah power
ready all right on your marks get that
go i gave up i'm just kidding
i won't
[Laughter]
when is this happening friday this is
happening friday at 9 00 a.m you could
definitely come support the firefighters
they'll love to have you cheer them on
and it's going to be outside so we can
all gather and have some fun and we're
also if you come to the store and you
purchase a waffle macchiato we donate a
portion of the um sale towards the
organization also and this is the
come cheer these guys on they're great
and thank you for what you guys